[Music]
Ever wonder about what he's
doing? how it all turned to
lies. Sometimes I think that it's
better to never ask
[Music]
[Applause]
why. Where there is desire, there is
going to be a flame. Where there is a
place going to get burned. But just
because it burns on me, you're going to
die. You got to get up and try
try. Got to get up and try
try. Got to get up and try try.
[Music]
Funny how the heart can be
deceiving more than just a couple times.
Why do we fall in love so
easy even when it's not
[Music]
right where there is desire there is
going to be a flame where there is a
flame someone's going to get burned but
just because it burns doesn't mean
you're going tonight. You got to get up
and try
try. Got to get up and try and try
try. You got to get up and try and try
try and try try.
[Music]
Ever worry that it might be
ruined? And does it make you want to
cry when you're out there doing what
you're
doing? Are you just getting
by? Tell me, are you just getting by by?
Where there is fire, there is going to
be a flame.
The flame is all about burn just because
it
burns going to die. You got to get out
and try
try. Got to get up and try
try. You got to get up and try
try. You got to get up and
try try. You got to get up and try
try. Got to get up and try try
[Applause]
try. You got to get up and try try try.
Got to get up and try try try.
[Music]
Hey there friends. So, I hope you
enjoyed that flow session. Uh, this one
is not sponsored. It's just that I was
at one of my favorite events here in DC
and I was inspired and I thought I would
break out some flow. That, by the way,
is the Kite Festival. That is a part of
the National Cherry Blossom Festival
that happens every spring here in DC and
it is one of my favorite local events.
Anyway, um just want to give a couple
quick shoutouts. Number one is to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyer Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video. And special thanks to the
non-B business friend of the channel
that is Becca Beckonin. Thank you so
very much for supporting my channel, my
work, and my mission. And also, this
video and all the videos on this channel
would not be possible without my amazing
supporters on Patreon. In particular,
I'd love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now. Thank you all so very much for
supporting my channel, my work, and my
mission. And if you'd like to get your
name in the credits or any of a host of
other awesome rewards, you can do that
by heading on over to my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo and signing up.
I'll leave a link to that down in the
description as well as up on screen
there. Not only will you get access to
those rewards, but also you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring PO
spinning and flow arts to the whole wide
world. So, go check that out, please and
thank you. And if you're dying to see
more of my flow uh sessions like this
one at various places around DC, I will
go ahead and leave a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up on screen. Thanks so much
for watching. Make sure to get out and
flow yourselves today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon. Take care
now. Peace.